what up guys welcome to the just hurry
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in let's get started
so there is
breaking news in the manosphere
the man the myth the legend that has
given dating advice for 20 years
is getting a divorce Steve Harvey is
rumored to be getting a divorce his wife
Marjorie was rumored to be sleeping with
the chef and his personal bodyguard on
top of that it's rumored that she is
trying to take half of his 400 million
dollar Fortune at 200 million
um and so it's interesting because while
this may be a shock to the general
public in the red pill space we Ben saw
this coming oh my gosh we then saw this
like we saw this come in like 10 years
ago because there's a couple red flags
with Marjorie number one
this woman was a single mother and as
much as we harp on single mothers and
you know people think we're just being
mean there is a reason why the red pill
guys and the manosphere guys adamantly
do not advise men to marry single
mothers there's no upside it shows they
have a proven track record of making bad
decisions and there really is no benefit
in marrying a single mother especially a
single mother whose daughter is a hoe
the apple does not fall far from the
tree and if the daughter's probably a
hoe the mom's probably a hoe she learned
it somewhere so let's let's pull the
clip of just some red flags that really
we have seen in the red pill and I'm
going to explain to you why they were
red flags when watching Steve and
marjorie's relationship Dynamics
where did I meet you
tell me first thing I said you I don't
know who this is but I'm gonna marry her
I mean sometimes it's just you got to
get away but you got to look you got to
look for the bright side and everything
and my bright side was her best thing
ever happened to me you know this girl
was like a like like everything for me
you know everything I was missing but
how did you know that she was more than
that
can I tell you something men know
y'all didn't really understand this men
know really we know if you're the one or
you're not all men can change and all
men will change but there's only one
woman that we're going to change for
he's just one
this is how I did it I flew to Cabo
Mexico
so we check into the hotel
she decides she's sleepy she doesn't
want to go to dinner this can't happen
because everything I've worked for is
gonna go down at this dinner so I talked
her into going to dinner I got a private
room inside of a wine cellar in comes
two Waiters with two huge white platters
with silver domes when they open up her
dome it had what looked like
a square piece of gelatin just sitting
there on the plate it was actually a box
and it was cracked
and when she realized that it wasn't
jello
she looked up under there and she said
oh my God and then she started crying
and I opened it up and there was a
rather nice sized diamond I just had a
moment
and that's me and my wife's song too
I met her 86 87 when the song came out
then God gave her back to me in 2005.
I put her name on the back man for you
you understand me
that's mine right there
yeah I own you and you own me
I will kill everybody in here about your
ass please understand that about the way
I love you Marjorie Elaine you
understand me I kill everybody in here I
swear to God you can ask the Lord about
me I'll kill everybody
[Applause]
we asked 100 married women
some days I'd be willing to trade my man
for a really good what
oh boy
what
did you just say
pool boy
thank you
[Music]
he tried it
you know uh my mom always had a phrase
growing up and she would always say
kidding is still half serious there's
some truth when you're joking around and
the fact that this woman had the
audacity to on a public platform
say that
she wants to trade her husband in for a
pool boy
really just shows a lack of respect
right and I I think that's what we see
in a lot of relationships it's like this
egalitarian model where women think it's
okay to publicly disrespect their man
they think it's funny and the issue with
Steve is he puts his woman on a pedestal
she clearly was not checked for a
lifetime
um a couple other red flags that I saw
all men can change but they only change
for the right woman well what does that
mean if the man is changing for the
woman that means she is leading the
relationship again this is just you know
I just personally believe there's a
natural order in the world that goes God
men women children and women need to
follow men and and in a relationship
Dynamic it doesn't work the other way
around you know
um it leads typically to divorce or
typically to the men being basically in
servitude to his woman for a lifetime
the other thing I noticed was he said he
talked her into going to dinner well
what does that tell you that she's
disagreeable like if your boss tells you
to do something you just listen you just
say okay but he has to talk his woman
into going to dinner
and you know I'm not saying we need to
psychoanalyze like every single time in
a relationship but my my whole point is
it really just shows the dynamic of the
relationship meaning they do what she
wants on her terms when she feels like
it
um and he just constantly puts this
woman on the pedestal she is a single
mother who he is putting above him the
man that's worth 400 million dollars
he is implying that the best thing that
ever happened to him was marrying a
single mother
what on Earth does this woman have that
that that is going to make the best
thing in a super accomplished guy's life
a woman and that's the problem in
societies we keep putting women on this
pedestal we keep saying women are the
prize women are the best thing that's
ever happened to us when really men are
the prize
yeah a guy like Steve Harvey many women
are going after
um I'm sorry but who has the leverage in
a relationship the single mother or the
rich comedian let's just call spade a
spade
um the other thing I I noticed Steve
Harvey said was he said I own you and
you own me again this goes back to the
egalitarian model and this is why
um a lot of times we really see
conservatives default to egalitarianism
like we are equal we are the same that's
why when we hear cheating right what is
the default from conservatives well you
know if I say you know we should work
through cheating for the men they'll say
well what about when a woman cheats
should the man stay again that's the
default to egalitarianism when we
covered Twitter erupting because Rachel
said her husband doesn't do chores they
default to egalitarianism and say well
if he loved her he would help well why
can't he help with the chores and again
relationships just work better when
people play their roles when women don't
expect men and to help out with the
domestic work again he said I own you
which is right he's half right and you
own me no no no no no again that that
implies egalitarianism equality and
that's why a lot of more conservative
people are Republican people default to
egalitarianism in their relationships
but they don't even know it so we have
even more you know red flags that the
red pill has seen in Steve Harvey for
years so you know pull up the clips I
told Marjorie when we first got married
I said baby listen to me I'll do
anything for you I give you the world
have I not done that you have done it
I say it only thing I don't do I don't
clean
now I got somebody now let's let's stop
faking I got four full-time jobs I got
somebody to clean behind me but Marjorie
wants me to clean this stuff up for the
housekeeper come what if I do that why
we paying her
it's a reflection guys imagine
the audacity
where we have a guy and I know this is
comedy I know it's funny but again
kidding is half serious we've got that
makes millions of dollars every year
takes a care of a hundred percent of the
bills comes home to a wife bitching
about him cleaning when he has a
housekeeper and this is what I mean guys
women we're just never happy don't try
to make a woman happy that's like that's
in our nature we'll just find something
to whine about now
I we can't even help it it's just like
we're just whiners we're big whiners
um so another another thing I noticed
you you'll see just the lack of General
respect she has for him when she's
deprecating her guy in public you know
the biggest thing to men is respect
respect is love and when you're making
fun of your guy in public that that's
extremely disrespectful another thing
that I thought was ironic how she's
talking about how he's a bad example for
the kids when her daughter is Lori
Harvey
are you kidding like
um and this is the thing
um
even the fact that they had a show
called makeover your man I love my man
but
shows just how much he panders and
caters to the female audience it's
always about men having to be better and
never about women improving and this is
something we've seen on TV in the media
in the church it's always about men
being better she's talking about her
needs but doesn't talk for a second
about his how ironic is it that it's
like what else does she do
like she doesn't have to work
so you can't clean like that's that's it
um and this is the thing guys a lot of
single mothers and predatory women will
become experts at making men feel loved
at learning the game just to get what
they want and then get what they want
and cheat later
um and that's why that's why you have
shows like fresh and fit telling you to
sleep with you know 10 20 30 40 50
Chicks before you settle down to you
don't get bamboozled by predatory women
so let me know your thoughts on Steve
Harvey if there's any other Clips you
want me to react to but I think we're
gonna keep seeing um guys that are more
blue pilled in their relationships more
idealistic ending up divorced ending up
cheated on and it's not something I wish
on anybody but the truth of the matter
is there's a natural order in the world
and relationships do not work when it's
out of order
when men put women on pedestals when men
believe that their woman is above them
that is disrupting the natural order of
the world when men give women leverage
because women can't have leverage unless
you give it to them so when men
pedestalize women so much that they give
them leverage it really just messes up
relationships we're going to keep seeing
them fail you know I saw a video from
like 50 years ago of a woman saying my
husband is the boss they said is your
husband the boss she said yes yes
and nowadays
that would be offensive does that woman
seem like she believes her husband's the
boss
does it seemed like he runs that
relationships relationships don't work
when the women run it always a risk of
investment and there's no guarantee of
any kind protect your retirement with
gold Ira or go to
www.justburlythingsgold.com or call
877-646-5347 Noble gold is who I trust
the US has lost 85 percent of its value
since the 70s when the dollar decoupled
from gold and the government seems bent
on continuing the tradition from now
until after the next elections the
government can print as much money as
they want and the last time they did
that inflation went up nine percent gold
is the one asset that has proven to
withstand inflation invest in gold with
a noble asset Investments you will also
get a 24 Karat quarter ounce gold
standard coin for free go to
noblegoldinvestments.com now that is
noblegoldinvestments.com
Com or simply dial
1-877-646-5347 Noble gold Investments
the only gold company that I trust
Okay so
um we're having a little segment called
Pearls of Wisdom where you know
the internet just gives me you know
questions I guess to give my my thoughts
my take on so
breaking up with my friend group for
horrible relationship advice that broke
up my marriage
my main group of friends is four other
women I met at University 10 years ago
we all met basically on the first week
of the first year and have stayed tight
with each other done then alive 10 years
ago I used to think they were all badass
and looked at them for advice for a lot
of stuff including relationships I
started seeing my now ex-husband six
years ago when we got married two years
ago and got separated one year ago and
now the divorce is final a lot of the
problems we had me acting on what in
hindsight seems like bad advice given to
me by friends example just after my
engagement they convinced me that I
shouldn't change my last name or
hyphenate because it was old-fashioned
and oppressive even though Mark told me
early on that it was an important thing
to him they planted doubts in my mind
about how what originally I thought were
innocent comments by his mom were Jabs
she was taking at me and pushed me to
force Mark to stand up for me to his mom
convinced me that I need to ration sex
because some stupid reason that I
brought into them now that doesn't make
sense convince me that when we have kids
they should take my last name because I
would be giving birth and again we
shouldn't support old-fashioned
Traditions with the last fight Mark said
he had enough and he wanted out and
initiated the breakup I was devastated I
foolishly thought he'd never leave me
because my friends convinced me that I
was way out of his league and he would
never leave me
I decided I can't be friends with these
women anymore because not only did they
give me really bad advice but when each
of them married none of them followed
any of the advice that had been so
important when they told me they each
took their husband's last name they all
bend over backwards to get along with
their in-laws no rationing of sex no
more kids need to get mother's last name
talk that just pissed me off and when I
confronted them I told them they were
using my marriage as a playground to
test their stupid relationship theories
and that they only started really
thinking things through when it came to
their own relationship I told them I
couldn't be friends with them anymore
they said I'm being unreasonable and
that they told me what they thought was
best at the time and that no one held a
gun to my head they're saying now that
they're in the position things are
different and they're saying it's a lot
more important to get along that's true
I'm probably going to be regretting this
for the rest of my life not using enough
of my own judgment on life decisions but
the thought that I had a good guy I
pushed away because of their advice is
too much for me am I wrong for cutting
them loose okay
all right all right all right so you
know what's funny with this shows
actually the real reason she got
divorced most likely
accountability
accountability well
you know when push comes to shove I
agree with the friends
nobody put a gun to your head nobody
made you do anything you didn't do
anything you didn't already want to do
you wanted to be difficult
and you found an excuse to be difficult
if it wasn't the friends it was going to
be social media if it wasn't social
media it was going to be a different
person that told you the same thing
because whenever women have to take
accountability for their decisions we
always look to the nearest person to
blame like who can we blame for this and
whoever is there that's who it's gonna
be now I think that she should have cut
her friends off but she should have did
it when she was married
um I don't think she's necessarily wrong
for cutting her friends off because I
think if she wants to be in a stable
loving relationship
um
women friends especially ones that
ruined your last marriage probably
aren't the best idea I'd imagine if the
women had these ideologies before when
gets tough they'll probably revert
back to them I really think listening to
this story really shows the real reason
she got divorced which is a lack of
accountability and that's what we see in
modern relationships we can't own up to
anything you know I give her some credit
where she did say that she ruined the
relationship by following this advice
but it's always what other people told
me to do and at some point if women we
wanted to be equal then be equal and
take accountability for the decisions
that you made you know imagine if a guy
came forward and said that he got
divorced because of what his friends
told him to do you would kind of look at
him like he's a bit silly and say well
you still did it like what if he said I
cheated because my friends told me to
would the women have a lot of sympathy
now now because he did what he was gonna
do you know
um but yeah that's my crazy lady advice
of the day I would agree stay away from
those friends
um maybe find some different non-liberal
married friends I really think young
women should embrace being friends with
old ladies that are married I was
thinking I'm like check out your local
nursing home because the women in that
generation the like
40 to 55 year old chicks they just
they really were the generation that
ruined marriage I got to be honest guys
they really were
and to show you guys how modern women
really are lost I want to give you guys
a clip from a dating coach giving really
great relationship advice just really
awesome
advice to have a long happy marriage you
asked man for money without feeling that
like this if you want to make me happy
right now
yeah of course I do
I'm gonna make you happy too
but later on
what do you want
then whisper in his ear like this
watch and give me as much money
as you choose that's kind of a kink I
just want to see what you're gonna give
example
okay let's go
then you're gonna say no never mind
you're gonna tease them a little bit
you're gonna say never mind
all right
how about
the next time we see each other you just
bring it to me
he already know he's going to do
something because you just whispered in
his ear
and you know what that do
Guy this is why women are so confused
because dating coaches like this will
give you games to play on men okay
they'll they'll do the 90-day rule
they'll play stupid games to get money
from them
and the truth of the matter is the men
that this would work on you will never
respect you will never like guys like
that it it will work on a sip and that's
and that's where I think women get
confused because we see the girls like
this get good outcomes and a lot guys a
lot of them do but the truth of the
matter is when they do get married it's
a Steve Harvey type relationship where
she's leading she's playing all of these
games to control him and at the end of
the day a woman will never respect a man
that she can control and it still messes
up the natural order of the world where
the men are supposed to lead us and
in this scenario who's late who's
leading this exchange and do you really
want a guy that you can control through
sex
is that is that really a guy that you
would respect and want to date and this
is the problem we have in society is
women we want all right I'm gonna I'm
gonna categorize the men in three
categories okay we have the sexless men
we have the simps and we have the
players and the guys that are the
players they're the ones screwing
everybody so they're just you know
screwing left and right and the reason
that women tend to like the players
partially is because they can't control
them
and these guys are going to do what they
want when they want and there's not
really you can do about it then we
got the Sims and The Sims don't realize
that all of the women they're talking to
are really going for the players so
the women will have no rules for the
players they'll let them do whatever
they want they'll let them walk all over
them that's what they always say I did
too much for him and that's where you
see like these trend of like the bitter
resentful women that feel used because
they shoot too high you know what I mean
it's like we'll go for the eights nines
and tens and they're just screwing
everybody good luck getting a guy with
like four five to settle
good luck and so what they'll do is
they'll adapt and then they'll play
these games on The Sims
and it'll work you know there are men
that are ruled by
you know vagina
um but they're never gonna be the guys
that you want I mean do you want a guy
that can be that easily controlled and
manipulated through sex and what happens
when another woman comes in and starts
to manipulate and control the guy
through the same thing but this is the
thing these are predatory women they
learn the game they learn
you know mind games they can play with
women and they pick a Target and they go
after him and sometimes they get it but
it always leads to destruction
relationships do not work like that even
if they stay together which most of the
time they won't but even if they do
the man is miserable they're both
miserable for a lifetime because she's
just you know women were never happy so
she's just trying to control him to do
all the things
um that she feels she wants him to do
and the men are trying to make the women
happy which ultimately makes the women
unhappy the US dollar has lost 85
percent of its value since the 70s when
the dollar decoupled from gold and the
government seems bent on continuing this
tradition from now until after the next
elections the government can print as
much money as they want and the last
time they did that inflation went up
nine percent that means one thing the
security of your future and your
family's future is all in your hands
make sure you freeze the value of the
wealth you are holding invest in gold
with Noble gold Investments gold is the
one asset that has proven to withstand
recession inflation and just above all
economic threats Noble gold Investments
is here to help you if you want to
invest in gold you will also get a 24
Karat quarter ounce gold standard coin
for free go to
noblegoldinvestments.com now that is
noblegold Investments Com or simply call
1-877-646-5347 Noble gold Investments
the only gold company that I trust
so I recently found a tick tock account
called homath where he basically breaks
down
what women are saying and I thought it
was hilarious that finally
the women are we're actually telling on
ourselves on Tick Tock and he just
really you know
breaks it down so go ahead
only 15 of women show an interest in
five eight men on dating apps I don't
know what I would do if I was short this
is a hard time for short men I this is
why dating apps are terrible when a
woman is looking at a dating app she can
just look at numbers on the screen and
set who she does and does not want to
talk to real life is different I once
went out with a girl and when I showed
up she said hey I thought you were six
foot three and I said no I don't lie on
my profile and I made her check and then
she saw that I was right and she said oh
okay and then we went and had a beer but
she was disappointed that I was five
foot eleven I guess she was talking to a
lot of guys we had fun anyway I also
have a friend who is five foot nine and
he once told me a story about meeting a
girl and flirting with her and she said
well you're short and I don't usually
date short guys and he didn't know what
to do with that and nothing ever
happened and my advice for him is the
same as my advice for you if you're in
the don't matter Zone with me
technically I'm in it too and that is
that when when that girl said usually I
don't usually date short guys what she
meant was keep going give me a reason
there are visible things about you and
there are invisible things about you
maybe you're funny or you're smart or
you're romantic and it takes women
longer to see those but they do see them
my five foot nine friend he uh got
married to an attractive intelligent
woman and they have a child which it
will grow up to be probably five foot
nine have the same problems but the
point is you can do it you just have to
go outside get get off the apps go
outside and tell women what's good about
you
don't get black pilled you can do it
it's possible
so okay the funny thing is and I
actually 100 agree with him especially
because I just think as a society we
always talk about all men are awkward
but I think women were just as awkward
we just get away with it because you
know we're like pretty and stuff so the
guys guys don't even care if you're
awkward but okay so
women filter out
men below six foot that is the most
common pick on the dating apps is they
just so if I was a dude I would lie I
would lie on dating apps I would
absolutely lie because the thing is he
is right women will date shorter but it
the shorter guys kind of have to have
something to make up for it but the
issue with tradcons is I just think a
lot of true ad cons are a bit oblivious
to just how picky the women are think
about it we've had 80 percent of men as
ugly 80 so I don't know if I was a guy
that was five three five four I don't
know what the hell I would do
today's market he had another video so
let's pull it up things I did not know
about men in my 20s except I'm still 20
but oh so then you did know them see
this is Peak female reasoning it doesn't
all make sense but she feels it she says
four things number one no men want
girlfriends that is false a lot of these
guys do it's just that you see them as
no one
number two most men are broke well yeah
most people are broke human beings
organize themselves into hierarchies
what do you want everyone wins it can't
I'm broke you want some oatmeal
number three if we wanted to then we
would and that is true unless we can't
so if he can and he won't he's not gonna
and number four he knows if he wants to
date you in the first 10 minutes that is
that's pretty true low rate of change on
that one but more importantly uh women
are confused that men know what they
want
buddy we're confused the men women
women project constantly so we
constantly project the way we feel onto
men so we're confused that they know
what they want because we don't know
what we want like it changes every
single day and even illogical things if
we feel a certain way
it does it doesn't even matter like if
we feel a certain way then we believe
it's true
um and the other thing is I think women
we have no idea just how much we really
only look at the top guys again women
again women find eighty percent of men
is ugly not unattractive not okay but
ugly and women usually I mean I think
with the a million videos we come out
with all these fat chicks saying that
they're tens can come to the conclusion
that most women overrate their beauty
and think they're more beautiful than
they are which really brings me to my
point that there's a lot of double
standards in society where women can get
away with a lot where men are punished
so so one thing that really red pilled
me one thing that really
um made me look at the world differently
was uh two stats okay one
are more likely to kill the elderly and
their own children
ninety percent of infant deaths from
parents is from the woman
so this idea that women are more
nurturing Kinder sweeter whatever it's
just not it's not real and the second
thing that really red pilled me was when
I realized most abuse is two-sided so
they're hitting the out of each
other and at that point you're just
fighting you're just fist fighting but
when it comes to one-sided abuse where
the woman's hitting the man and the
man's not retaliating or the man's
hitting the woman and the woman's not
retaliating women overwhelmingly hit men
more than men hit women and I wanted to
demonstrate this in a clip that I saw go
viral on fresh and fit what about you
have you ever disrespected a boyfriend
significant living in public yes it was
one night like I got very drunk at a
party it was something so stupid it was
that I fell down a step and he was
trying to grab me my boyfriend was
trying to grab me and we fell and I
thought that he pushed me and I thought
it was his fault and I'm a very
aggressive drunk so like I don't care
what anyone does or says I'm gonna punch
you so yeah I punched him okay so you
thought that he pushed you down the
stairs yeah so I just started yelling at
him and screaming at him and cursing him
there were people watching and yeah but
he's an abusive relation that's
what I'm here no like you physically
abused him as long as you don't get me
drunk we're okay fantastic
yeah imagine if the tables were reversed
okay imagine if a guy said yeah I
thought she hit me yeah so I just
started screaming at her and I hit her
and then the women say well isn't that
abusive and you know he kind of laughs
it off and says okay only when I'm drunk
and this really shows that we really
don't have sympathy for men
women can go on public platforms and
admit to abuse and there's no backlash
there's no crying this didn't this you
know I mean it went viral in red pill
spaces but this wasn't a national news
nobody covered this because people don't
really care when men get abused they
don't see it as abuse there's a lack of
sympathy for men in society and I really
do think it's innate like I think it
just goes to a biological level where
men just have an innate protection of
women and really just we see men as
Expendable and disposable and I think
that's why we really need to push for
men to have equal protections under the
law for whatever reason you know men
really aren't taken seriously when it
comes to abuse so much so that men will
call the police on a woman and they'll
end up arresting the man due to the
Duluth model that was implemented in the
70s where they automatically see the men
as the aggressor and the perpetrator and
this Vision that feminists have painted
in the justice system and the media that
men are just these abusers is false it's
wrong it's just not true and we need to
stop viewing women as these innocent
victims that do nothing wrong so
um let me know what you guys want me to
cover tomorrow send me any topics to
just pearly things one thank you guys so
much for watching like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel and
I'll talk to you next time